let's try instead harry from columbus
ohio
david can you hear me yes i can
thank you so much for taking my call
firstly i wanted to
raise a quibble with how you pronounce
um a certain set of words now whenever
you are using the word historic i
noticed that you will say a
or an historic
um which
i have no understanding of why you would
say and historic could you care to
explain that
yeah
this is a this is a topic of big debate
among the uh grammar uh nazis and
pronunciation experts
there are certain
typically the rule would be that if the
word starts with a vowel
it would be an and if the word starts
with a consonant it would be a so a cat
versus an apple the thing about real
quickly
just before we want so i know you're
talking about and if we use the word
let's say hour
like the hour of the day we would say oh
it took an hour to get there because we
pronounced the word hour with a silent h
yes correct yes the word historic we do
not have a silent h we have a very hard
h well the thing about batteries and i
apologize uh in order to
fight back against your interruption i
am now going to interrupt
the thing about historic is there are
some words where when pronounced in
isolation
they have a very clear consonant sound
like if i just say
historic but historic has a relatively
soft h when in context and that is why
my understanding is that it is
acceptable to say
and historic and you're kind of running
it together
if that is how you see it i i can't
disagree with it we'll just have to
agree to disagree on that that's fair um
secondly real quickly and i wanted to
get into this how do you feel about
that now that jd vance has completely
you know kind of fallen off the wagon a
bit in my opinion yeah how do you feel
about josh mandel gibbons with the with
the pre-note that you know mandel ran
against um senator
uh what's his what's his name
in 2012 he ran against the current
democratic senator um
from ohio
i think that they're all toxic i think
that all of those republican primary
candidates are all completely toxic now
you're completely right like listen a
couple years ago i bought the book
hillbilly elegy everybody said listen
this book this is a good
story
of growing up in the rural poor white
midwest and south you'll understand
conservatism you should really read this
book and i read jd vance's book
and first of all i mean his grandma as
he writes in the book was like a kennedy
democrat so it's not even like it wasn't
even that great of an expose about
conservatism because his family was
actually sort of liberal but anyway i
was like okay this is like a thinking
guy
and he has gone completely off the rails
pro trump or at least hesitating to
criticize trump and just bottom of the
barrel
red meat
he's absolutely i'm embarrassed that i
thought he was mildly reasonable after
reading the book
yeah i could see where that perspective
came from and a lot of people still hold
that perspective without the knowledge
of what he said otherwise now real quick
before i drop mandel i think if mandel
starts the third i don't think trump
will throw his hat in their end i think
he'll see that mandel lost in 2012 he's
a loser quote unquote um i expect mike
gibbons to really start to pull ahead if
trump you know nominates or you know
trump has been extremely extremely
scared to put his voice like into this
race yeah i think he may just be waiting
to see how it shakes out before he does
when's the primary there
the primary is may 3rd but as you may or
may not have heard we've had a lot of
issues regarding
uh congressional maps lots of
time in the supreme court of ohio
and as of yesterday ohio aclu is suing
the the gop map makers so it's it's
still got a lot of story left to play
out here in ohio thanks for taking call
david hey real quick are you talking
through a voice modulator or through
some kind of metal screen
i am using a bluetooth headset that is
probably not the optimal way of talking
i'll try to get on a better microphone
next time we speak thank you for
beautiful all right thank you so much i
appreciate the call
wow what a phone call guys it is really
something else today